Earlier in this
course, we talked
about the changing
role of labor unions
and how the decline
in union membership
has contributed to the breakdown
of the social contract.
To understand this
better, let's look
at how union membership rates
have changed since their peak
in the 1950s, when almost
one third of all employees
belonged to a union.
By the early 1980s,
around the time when
we began to see the real
effects of the breakdown
of the social contract,
union membership
was already declining.
And from then until now,
it declined even more
dramatically.
In 2013, only 11% of 129 million
working individuals in the US
had a union on the job and
collective bargaining network.
Now, in the private sector,
which employees most
working individuals in the US,
this percentage is even lower--
barely 7% of these workers
in fast food, health care,
or technology, for example,
barely 7% have a union at work.
Now, labor leaders and scholars
who study employment and labor
unions argue that
a number of factors
have contributed to
this decline in unions.
Some argue, for example, that
the structure of the economy
plays a role, as growth in
non-union sectors concentrated
in service industries
has outstripped growth
in industries like
construction and manufacturing
where unions historically
have been strong.
Others point to the increased
difficulty of organizing
new membership,
and in particular,
to the legal obstacles
that exist in implementing
new agreements at work.
Recent research has found that
only one in seven workplaces
where workers have organized an
election and voted for a union
will actually see a contract in
the year following their vote.
And oftentimes, these types
of elections are contentious.
And in workplaces
where employers
have been charged with
trying to discourage union
activity through
unfair labor practices,
the odds go down
by nearly a third.
In addition to these economic
and legal challenges,
labor leaders and
scholars also point
to increased
anti-union activity,
not only by employers, but
increasingly by policymakers,
as we've seen in states
like Wisconsin and Indiana,
who are rolling back
workers' rights to organize
and collective
bargaining agreements.
So over the past
three decades, there's
really been a shift, not only
in how many people experience
labor unions on the job,
but in the way that we
think about labor unions.
In this course, we've talked
about the social contract
and what it means at work--
this idea that what's good for
workers is good for businesses.
And although we have examples
of many good employers
as discussed by Professor
Zeynep Ton in her video,
many employers act
as though this idea
is no longer the case--
that what's good
for workers is not
necessarily good for businesses,
and that unions do not
have a role in improving
the way that firms work.
At the same time, declining
wages, less job security,
and increased costs related
to things like health care
and student loans
are making it more
difficult for
working individuals.
All of this adds up to
a difficult environment,
not only for labor
unions, but also
for individuals
who try to protect
their rights on the job.
The good news, however, is
that over the past two decades,
we've had a flurry of
activity in organizing around
economic justice in ways
that are bringing employees'
voices front and center.
These include new
strategies of labor unions
to expand their membership
and include more working
people, the growth of
worker centers and labor
associations outside this
realm, and the strengthening
of employment policy through
economic development.
We've also seen a growing
number of social movements
that are highlighting the ways
in which the social contract
can be reestablished at work.
In the next video,
we'll talk about each
of these in a bit more detail.